I am Dan are you gonna drive up and fly
up today I want you to drive because
we've got some thunder and lightning in
here and I don't think it's a very good
day to be flying into Boston so
hopefully the the wheels will be rolling
along the Turnpike and I'm assuming
you're gonna come by land right yeah I
was gonna walk but I'm I am gonna take a
car right after the show and hopefully
there'll be a greeting party when I get
to the hotel or by boat one if by land
two if by sea you know we're in the
right place we're for a little bit of
history I love Boston is such a great
city all right when when you go in to a
game like that is there anything
different about the season opener as far
as preparation approach then it would be
if you know it's week three yeah a
little different in the sense that for
the most part you're concentrating a
little bit more on the guys that are new
the people who you know who weren't here
last year
counting Kansas City's number one
running back for instance is a rookie
Kareem hunt he's gonna take over of
course because Spencer where it got hurt
you've got a lot of new guys playing for
the Patriots as well so you know we'll
do a little bit more work on these
people coming in but and the other thing
I love about this game is that there's a
mystery involved here that you don't get
in any other game three four or five
weeks into the season certainly at the
end of the season you kind of know where
where teams are and where they've been
and the possibilities and the prospects
and all the rest so you know this is
kind of like breaking the seal you begin
the year and and and then it's its
mysterious I look at you know I look at
this game you look at New England and
there's a reason why people are you know
talking about a perfect season I mean I
can't think of a team a Super Bowl
champion that had a better off season
the Edelman injury notwithstanding I
mean they look like they're a better
team than they were last year when they
only lost two games and one of them was
when Brady was hurt earlier in the
season so they're tough I mean they are
the legitimate Superbowl favorites no
question do you make a Super Bowl
prediction I don't I mean years ago I
was in a restaurant
alyssa was 1994 the waiter came by he
wanted to know who I thought would wind
up in the Super Bowl and you know as a
joke I said San Diego and they got there
of course they were routed by San
Francisco so I Danny I don't do that
anymore I mean yes people everybody
wants it's like only the Kentucky Derby
I did a bunch of derbies you know at ABC
between 86 and 2001 drilldowns and
people would say who's your Derby horse
I would I would go I would go Seabiscuit
[Laughter]
but but you're aware of the point spread
in the over-under sure did yours did you
bet no I don't you know in in my book
and I love the way you positioned my
book on I love that every time I'm on
you know you get that book right there
it's beautiful
it's I appreciate that tremendously dan
I wrote in the book I said if I had to
make my living betting on sports and
look as much as I know I know more than
most people are going to know obviously
because we have greater access but the
one thing I love about sports is you
don't know it's so unpredictable so if I
had to bet on sports I would be living
in a trailer park somewhere in the
Mojave Desert do you ever doubt yourself
your abilities was there ever a moment
and even recently where you just go I am
I getting better or my you know my
slipping or any insecurity I don't think
well I you know when you start your
career obviously you know you hit some
breaks I mean I did the World Series
when I was 27 years old and I'm thinking
to myself oh my god I could end my
career you know was a bad performance I
don't have that now obviously all these
years into my career but I'm driven by
doing every game better than I did the
last game or any other game I've done
and I think and you know our crew I
think we just feed off each other and a
great broadcast is a team it's it's
teamwork
you can't do it without Fred Goodell he
and drew a cigar fan all and you know
all the guys obviously and and Chris and
Michelle and I of course are in the
limelight but we're doing it with 70
people
we we drive each other we drive each
other too we think of every Sunday night
game as a mini Super Bowl and then this
year we get to do the real Super Bowl
Bowl I don't think we approach that game
any differently than we do any other
game we just we're there every week and
and I think our our feeling is our hope
is hey we're gonna do this game better
than any game we've ever done and that's
what I'm driven by so it's not a
question of doubting myself it's a
question of hey come on Ratchet it up
and let's go and let's be on top of it
must be perfect he's how Michaels NBC
Sunday Night Football also Thursday
night with the Chiefs Patriots from
Foxborough speaking of the Cowboys the
Ezekiel Elliott storyline that he does
get to play on Sunday night I don't know
how it affects because you just call
what you see but how much commentary do
you think Chris makes in you know in
accordance to Ezekiel Elliott playing
and what this means at because we're
gonna find out I think Friday if he's
gonna be able to you know play any
further than Game one right I mean look
we report the facts and if we want to
weigh in with commentary we can and
obviously you know you guys are gonna
cover it on football night so people
that people are gonna know about it
they're gonna hear about it they've read
about it so if there's something new
obviously we'll get into that and then
you know of course where I have we have
a feeling about what we think is going
to happen or what has happened yeah I
mean no holds barred in terms of that
but you know it's not a case during the
game it's very very hard people don't
want to be lectured certainly during the
game and by the time people tune in to
watch the game that's what they will
that's what they're there for
they want the game and I always you know
you and I have talked about this in the
past I find it very difficult to get
into something complicated and complex
and controversial and then all of a
sudden the guy launches a 60-yard pass
every touchdown
yeah and then you stop you have to stop
on a dime you can't get back to it it
becomes totally disjointed so these are
stories that are you know can be well
told on pregame shows or written about
in columns and all of the rest very
difficult to weave in when they're that
complicated
and it's not that we're avoiding it but
you know people have heard about it
know about it they want to watch the
game I still go back to Monday Night
Football the phenomenon of Monday Night
Football that you had luminaries
stopping by the booth you know when John
Lennon stopped by the booth when you
know Monday Night Football was in its
infancy like can you can you let the
audience even know you know with you
just being in the business to understand
what the magnitude
you know what the fallout was of Monday
Night Football the impact it had on on
sports and really outside of sports well
if you go back to when it started in
1970 I mean the National Football League
was maybe 40% is popular or whatever
percentage you want to put on it as it
is right now it certainly I mean
baseball was still probably America's
pastime football was becoming America's
pastime now of course there's no
question you know foot-post far more
popular than baseball obviously all you
have to do is look at the ratings but it
was the first time that you would see
you know a prime-time game and in those
years Sudan you had basically no cable
television yeah certainly not the way we
know it today you had the three major
networks Fox wasn't even existing as a
network at that particular point and a
couple of local stations and a lot of
people were watching television with
rabbit ears and tinfoil wrapped around
the rabbit ears to get better reception
so this was different and then it was
played under the lights and you didn't
see football played under the lights for
the most part until Monday Night
Football started so and then you had you
know Cosell was in there as the
lightning rod you had dandy Don doing
his thing Frank Gifford was in the
second year after Keith Jackson had done
year one you know Frank came and so they
it the show had a look to it uh you know
a patina to it that nothing else had and
then of course you know through the
years it became more and more primetime
games and the cable television came in
and all of the rest so it lost a little
bit of that specialness and in terms of
bringing celebrities into the booth yeah
when you brought a John Lennon in I mean
that was terrific
but I know in some of the years that I
was as ABC we had a couple of people who
were running the entertainment division
and they wanted every you know
Remiel who was doing a cockamamie sure
that would get canceled their to three
weeks to come into the blue to her moat
the show that was no good and that you
know that had that helped to take a lot
of the luster away so we try we try not
to do that I mean you know if it's like
a gigantic celebrity a you know I
remember the night of the of the Jets
Dolphins game which was a fantastic game
in two thousand and there was a game in
which the Jets affected that tremendous
comeback wanted overtime the game and
there's a white one sixteen in the
morning we had Arnold Schwarzenegger
coming to the booth so that was big at
that pending at the point and and and
the Jets were trailing but like twenty
four and Arnold it the Arnold was ready
you know he was gonna leave at halftime
anyways rod you watch the Jets are win
the game so the next day on CNN Headline
News they played that clip of
Schwarzenegger who's just throwing some
stuff out randomly and sure enough you
know the Jets won that game but it's no
it's a burden have most of those people
in the booth you got dinner plans
tonight we do not quite sure where it
will be but you know there'll be a stake
at hand what about you
I don't know once I get up there then
they they put me to work but I have no
idea like I just go where they tell me
to go out all work and no meal yeah
Danny very unhappy boy yeah right well
maybe we'll cross paths up here oh they
got some fantastic restaurants up here
mistrial is fantastic love that to the
court or how many join us on the road
this year I don't know for joining us at
Thanksgiving and then I'll be there it's
Super Bowl as well beautiful yeah I love
it
I'll see you a little bit later on
you're on the Greyhound bus that's me
like a couple connections Pacific thank
you Dad cell Michaels the Dan Patrick
show weekday mornings on audience